du général de gaulle et de monsieur rené
coty ils sont arrivés devant la tribune
officielle et après avoir salué le
drapeau de la gare et de week-end
il remonte à bord de leur voiture pour
aller tout au long de l'avenue des
champs elysées jusqu'à la place de
l'étoile et dans l'avenue de la
grande-armée passé en revue les troupes
qui prendront part au défi
au rond point des champs elysées sur le
chemin du retour le président de la
république et le général de gaulle fois
redescendu de voitures devant la nouba
les tirailleurs algériens et cette fois
le général de gaulle prend congé de
monsieur rené coty avant de gagner
villacoublay d'où un esso bretagne
l'emmènera directement vers toujours au
général de gaulle assistera à la revue
navale pour l'instant c'est le défilé
aérien avec les vampires mystère et le
final l'apothéose du filet 3 c'est sous
la fumée bleue leur père ont retracé
dans le ciel très bleu ce matin et
redwood parce
et le dessiner des troupes terrestres
emmenés par des éléments de la
gendarmerie et les mouvementée d'abord
qui vous venez de voir passer
voici d'autres à bord de quatre axes
c'est à dire de véhicules à aux motrices
les deux miches nier qu'ils sont les
véhicules de base de l'infanterie porter
les armées modernes et toujours
appartenant à la gendarmerie
les chars
sharp a tough
c'est à dire chargé par les plus lourds
actuellement ces apps
un escadron de l'art gendarmerie mobile
voici le général qui couvre le défilé
des troupes blindées
et
le 1er régiment de marche du tchad qui
est devenu depuis qu'il a participé à la
libération de paris dans les rangs de la
2e db qui est devenu l'un des régiments
de traditions de la région parisienne
est également monté à bord d'art traces
ce régiment avait été l'un des premiers
régiments reconstitué en afrique et
avait pris part à tous les combats de la
colonne leclerc depuis le fezzan jusqu'à
la france jusqu à alençon jusqu'à paris
jusqu'à strass
le défilé les blindés se poursuit la
caméra qui vous le montre ici est situé
en haut de l'arc de triomphe
et voici les deux autour blindé de
reconnaissance du 2e régiment de
hussards
non excusez moi ce sont les chars patton
les chars patton du 501e régiment de
chars de combat qui est également un
ancien régiment de la 2e division
blindée de la division leclerc et qui
est devenu l'un des régiments de la
région parisienne
cantonné à rambouillet
3e régiment d'artillerie coloniale la
prison
et un détachement de la police routière
ces simulations au tiers 602 avec mes
hommes casque blanc que vous avez
reconnu les casques de la police
militaire
et voici
toujours sur aff tracks voici les
chasseurs n'ont pas les chasseurs à pied
bien longtemps mais les chasseurs
portait précisément le 2ème bataillon de
chasseurs qui est porteur
du drapeau des chasseurs vous savez
qu'il n'existe pour tous les bataillons
de chasseurs qu'un seul drapeau dont
chaque bataillon à tour de rôle à la
garde est en quelque sorte le
dépositaire
et derrière les chasseurs les engins
antichar téléguidé du 13e régiment de
tirailleurs algériens
c'est richard télédiffusé antichars
derrière une jeep est passé
à présent les compagnies sahariennes
porte et trois pelotons de compagnie
saharienne dont les hommes sont
traditionnellement depuis le demandant
la perrine des gardiens du désert et
maintenant ils gardent l'entraînement de
désert mais il garde également le
pétrole du désert
des batteries cracked et du 1er régiment
d'artillerie coloniale
le ses batteries débattre ou 255 et
voici maintenant un détachement
techniques du génie
à nouveau l'artillerie pièce 255
encore à l'état chevaux raté
les camions porte grue
le 5e régiment de gym exactement
un régiment de transmissions le 8e
régiment de transmissions qui est le
régiment du mont valérien
et à présent les sapeurs pompiers de
paris qui furent très acclamé ce matin
sur les champs-elysées avec leur
détachement dis détachement de guerre
camille enfin en kaki et laure
détachement civile dans détachement de
paix avec les camions vin de couleur
écarlate que vous venez c'est bien
et pour terminer le défilé des troupes
motorisées les sanitaires les ambulances
les dépasser voici une de nos caméras
sur le sommet de l'arc de triomphe est à
présent précédée de la nouba de deux
noubas même de tirailleurs algériens
celle du 1er régiment et celle du 13e
régiment de tirailleurs algériens les
débats elle même précédée du bouc
traditionnelle du doubs que mascotte
voici le dessiner des anciens
combattants d'afrique du nord ce qui ne
s'était jamais produit un défilé de 14
juillet de faire défiler des civils
puisqu'il anciens combattants avec des
militaires les anciens combattants
d'afrique du nord que vous allez voir
passer ils sont au nombre de 4000 ha en
ce moment la musique que la nouvelle
idée derrière j'ai rien des bois
précisément pour pouvoir ce qu'en b pour
pouvoir scandé le passage d
c'est un battant le voici
ils sont donc quatre mille venue de
département d'alger venu d'oran venue de
constantine quatre mille anciens
combattants de souche
une horde africaine et des six
européenne environ dans la proportion de
9 2-9 musulmans au 9 de souche lord
africaine ni pour un euro v
la plupart d'ailleurs de ses anciens
combattants sont des hommes venus du
bled venue d'edouard d'un des mechtas
que l'on a choisi dans ces régions de
préférence aux villes et vous pouvez
voir que beaucoup d'entre eux portent
d'ailleurs des djellabas apporte des
jets chanturgue année autour du crâne
c'est à dire porte pratiquement les
vêtements c'est que l'on y rencontre
lorsque l'on circule dans le bled
algérien
tantôt aux anciens combattants d'origine
européenne qui se trouvent dans ces
fonds ils ont été choisis par les ceux
qui n'avaient que peu d'occasions de
venir en métropole
quoiqu'il y ait plus de parents ni
d'amis soit plus d'une année tout
simplement par les moyens on leur offre
est ternie nantes se définit les anciens
combattants algériens celui des anciens
combattants du sahara bank aux costumes
extrêmement caractéristiques variées
voire plus encore
voici ce qu'on appelle les hommes bleus
qui porte la pratiquement la djellaba de
nos pensées des compagnies sahariennes
il porte dans le désert
et puis derrière les anciens combattants
d'algérie apparaissent les jeunes
d'algérie 2000 jeunes gens venus des
départements algériens et qui sont
précédées par et le fanion et par les
élèves moniteurs de l'école dit soir qui
forment précisément des moniteurs les
moniteurs musulmans des moniteurs
africains pour encadrer la jeunesse
musulmane algérienne les trois
compagnies présentes ici de l'école
l'histoire qui défilent en treillis bleu
roi béret noir
et des jeunes on n'est jamais ils sont
je crois vous avoir dit 2000 également
originaires des départements d'alger de
constantine et d'oran appartenant pour
la plupart à des mouvements de jeunesse
parfois ils ont encore beaucoup à
apprendre dans l'art de défiler les
allées très content d'être là et je
crois qu'ils ont été encore beaucoup
plus heureux de l'accueil qui leur a été
réservé par le public parisien
extrêmement chaleureux ce matin
également parmi ces jeunes même
proportion environ neuf musulmans de sa
fréquence pour un européen
comme je vous disais ils ont encore
beaucoup à apprendre dans l'art de
décider mais ce sont des choses que ça
prenne
et à présent les troupes à pied les
troupes à pied et pour commencer la
musique de l'école préparatoire
militaire d'aix-en-provence il est en
réalité à l'école des enfants
une compagnie de cette école militaire
d'aix en provence
les filles entend vareuse bleue foncée
les bleus
et la musique une musique mixte
d'infanterie coloniale composé par
moitié des éléments de la musique du
régiment de marche du tchad et
d'éléments du 3ème régiment d'infanterie
coloniale
ces musiques très cède 8 écoles d'autres
pays peuvent et du tout à l'heure à
l'instant même l'école l'ex en provence
et voici je n'ai pas besoin de le
préciser
l'école polytechnique
ce
je
civ et mathématicien les scientifiques
ce qui est une raison supplémentaire
pour qu'en ce qui me concerne je
m'abstienne de commenter davantage ces
images ne seraient absolument incapable
et derrière polytechnique là aussi les
avait reconnus voici casar et gants
blancs et sa syrien selon leur est resté
bien que nos écoles soit fait saint cyr
voici les élèves de l'école militaire
interarmes de coëtquidan
la musique de l'école navale le drapé de
l'école navale
mais non c'était bien la musique de
l'école n'a ramené c'est maintenant
l'école de l'aer l'école de
salon-de-provence du foot
et à nouveau des deux mains noires et
des licornes
mais cette fois ci ce ne sont pas des
politiciens c'est l'école militaire de
médecine l'école de lyon et pour
terminer l'école de formation des cadres
de la france d'outre-mer l'école de
fréjus et qu'ils préparent peut
nullement parmi les hommes et parmi les
sous-officiers venus des territoires me
promettent ils préparent des officiers
pour encadrer nos unités d'infanterie
coloniale
cette musique est évidemment la musique
de la garde républicaine
qui précède la suite du défilé des
troupes à pied tout à l'heure nous avons
vu les écoles nous allons voir
maintenant les différentes unités
combattantes
la garde à vue du kent tout d'abord créé
sous l'envi une première en plus et les
sous le nom de garde municipal puis se
bâtit d'ailleurs beaucoup tentent 6
affriolants l'espagne burgos
un détachement à pied de la gendarmerie
mobile dont vous avez vu tout à l'heure
les éléments motorisés les éléments
blindé face à cette armée
et à présent la musique du 93e régiment
d'infanterie le régiment traditionnel de
la vendeuse mais devenu depuis 1946 l'un
des résidents de la région parisienne
je résume enfin je veux les dix était le
gisement de vendée c'est dans ses rangs
car servier durant la guerre de 14-18
celui qui serait un jour dans les femmes
delattre et qui fait vendéen et c'est
précisément le général de la truck tu
parles mal la guerre après avoir
reconstitué son 93e l'a fait venir à
paris d'où il n'est pas parti puis il
file à des régiments témoin de la
nouvelle armée française tel que l'avait
souhaité telle qu'elle n'avait
reconstituer le général de lattre au
lendemain de la guerre
les musiques des tirailleurs ligne ou
bas le général morlière gouverneur
militaire de paris qui présente les
troupes au président de la république
et la musique à présent du bataillon de
joinville
vous savez que le bataillon de joinville
et un bataillon de sportif dans lequel
les l'athlète les champions même les
futurs champions champions de classe
nationale de classe internationale et
leurs cadets peuvent faire leur service
militaire peuvent remplir leurs
obligations militaires sans cessé de
remplir leurs obligations de sportifs
c'est à dire qu'ils subissent
parallèlement une instruction militaire
et un entraînement intensif chacun dans
leur spécialité
e
elle a cédé indiciels à la droite de
monsieur rené coty se trouve monsieur
être au caire puis dans l'assemblée
nationale tient à sa guise il trouve
l'avait aperçu monsieur monnerville
président du conseil de la république
est à présent précédé d'une d'une
musique de l'infanterie coloniale
voici les troupes qui arrivent d'afrique
du nord ancien régiment de marche qui a
été composé d'éléments appartenant à
tous les régiments d'infanterie qui se
battent actuellement en afrique du nord
il y a trois bataillons composant ces
risques
trois bataillons dont l'un représente
les troupes de l'algérois l'autre les
troupes puis constantinois et le
troisième les troupes de l'oranais si
bien que toutes les unités d'infanterie
qui sont des plus en présente en algérie
et qui s'y battent se trouve en même
temps représenté ici par quelques-uns de
leurs jeunes de l'or l'officier de leurs
deux fils y est trié j'imagine selon
leur mérite car j'ai remarqué ce matin
pendant le reportage en direct que la
plupart d'entre eux portait à la
poitrine
la croix de la valeur militaire qu'ils
avaient reçus lors des combats arnal g
un régiment de tirailleurs algériens à
présent qui est le premier régiment de
tirailleurs âgées régiment qui se trouve
actuellement également en asie
ils ont remarqué que les officiers
sous-officiers portes de callot azur
fairly que les hommes portent le turban
blanc traditionnel des turcos comme on
appelle les tirailleurs et air algérie
en l'occurrence
un autre régiment de tirailleurs
également précédé de sa nouba et d'un
book dont je me souviens que les cornes
été peintes de couleurs d'or c'est le
13e régiment de tirailleurs algériens
qui est cantonné en allemagne à lambda
et la musique la nuit bas de ces
tirailleurs les hommes de cette loi
portent le costume de tradition des
tirailleurs avec le petit boléro bleus
le roi a par mangeons qui vit en
broderie et le pantalon très très large
comme vous voyez c'est une tenue dont il
reste je crois assez peu l'exemple et
que l'on doit très rarement dans les
défilés de dit m
là encore le calot azur a crevé gentil
et le turban fournisseurs
elle
hélas une nouba celles qui avaient
scandé le décider des anciens
combattants des boîtes et en même temps
emboîtent le pas aux deux régimes
antérieurs qui viennent de décider
oui
l'infanterie coloniale l'infanterie
coloniale en l'occurrence le 1er
régiment d'infanterie coloniale qui est
un régiment dont les hommes et dont les
tambours ils voyaient portent l'insigne
de la croix de lorraine un signe des
français libres car ce régime en fut
l'un de ceux qui composèrent la première
division française libre c'est-à-dire la
division de juin 40 pour faire gore
l'embryon fille formé en juin 40
la division la division des gaullistes
de la première était poursuivi ces
combats jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
voici les hommes qui sont les héritiers
les traditions de cette première les ffl
les tirailleurs sénégalais de fréjus
et d'instruction et territoires
d'outre-mer
si vous avez des niveaux d de fréjus et
ceux de nos téléspectateurs qui habitent
la région ça on y rencontre beaucoup de
tirailleurs sénégalais et cela depuis la
guerre de 14-18 simorre région
d'élections pour des raisons climatiques
bien facile à comprendre
et à présent la musique de la brigade
des parachutistes colonies
où
omar seck les parachutistes des fissures
un pas assez curieux appartenait pas
tout à fait aussi lent que celui de la
légion vous verrez tout à l'heure qui
était un peu roulé un peu traîné un pas
assez décontracté évidemment qui n'est
tout de même pas très militaire en
entier probablement parachutistes
et voici la léchère voici la musique de
la légion étrangère et voici précisément
ce parent très spécial très lent très
noble
de la mission française
la légion sideci évidemment en juin ça
marche traditionnelle la marche google
le drapeau du 1er régiment étranger de
parachutistes
cette fois à délaisser le béret vert des
parachutistes étaient tombés pour le
képi à housse blanche qui est lui aussi
l'une des traditions de la légion avec
les épaulettes vertes et rouges
5e compagnie de la légion étrangère deux
compagnies je produis parachutistes
coloniaux
une compagnie du régiment de marche du
1er régiment de marche que la légion une
autre compagnie de parachutistes
coloniaux et pour terminer d'une
compagnie représentant la 13e demi
brigade de légion
les unités une fameuse de la guerre
39-45 puisque je fais ma 13e demi
brigade de bir-hakeim deuxième de livry
gamme de la dfl oxydes vision de la
france libre les la musique des
équipages de la flotte
le drapeau du 1er régiment le fusilier
marin blindés c'est à dire les marais
qui normalement et s'il à bord de chars
ils ont combattu durant la dernière
guerre à bord de chars tant dans les
rangs de la 2e db que dans les rangs de
la 1re dfl commandos de la marine
la musique de l'air à présent
des détachements de l'armée de l'air qui
complète dans quelque sorte
de façon plus visible longuement
visiteurs luca le défilé aérien qui a
précédé celui d'être terrestre
et clôturant ce défilé militaire du 14
juillet 1958 à paris les troupes montées
et dernières troupes montées de l'armée
française la fanfare de la garde
républicaine à cheval de paris
l'étendard de la garde
et la gare
et les spahis le septième escadron de
spy alger
et c'est ce pays clôture ce défilé
militaire ont toujours
traditionnellement clôturée par les
troupeaux cheval c'est le président la
république va maintenant quitter la
tribune officielle
il a félicité le général morlier un
gouverneur militaire de paris
il y avait présenté les troupes il l'a
félicité selon la formule pour la bonne
tenue de ses troupes et le président
ayant à sa gauche le général general
sécrétaire général militaire de l'elysée
va maintenant regagner son talent et par
l'avenue marie